qui me choque hier quand on en parlait
on a justement essayé d'éviter cet
écueil parce que c'est un écueil trouver
à un moment des raisons alors qu'on est
dans l'émotion c'est très compliqué
maintenant admettons on va faire comme
si les Israéliens l'avaient bien mérité
hein l'avit bien mérité mais exactement
ce que tu dis quelle honte mais c'est ce
que tu viens de qu h est-ce qu' y a des
gens qui ont pe de lucidité autour de ce
PL ce que tu dis depuis tout à l'heure
c'est que tu 75 ans il il faut un moment
Karim assume ce que tu
dis pe laiss
moi je vous dis que c'est
honte Tu Vi dire Tu Vi hte
de dire pourquoi tu as dit qu'il avait
des causes tu as dit qu'il y avait des
causes écoute et regarde-moi bien dans
les yeux parce que je va poser une
question et elle est CLA si on estime
que la politique israélienne on va dire
est responsable de ce qui s'est passé
moi je vais te dire un truc qu'a mérité
la France pour avoir connu le Bataclan
vas-y mais quel est le rapport entre VO
le combat le combat voilà l'aspiration
d'un peuple qui serit peutêtre tu peux
juste me répondre mais je te demande
parce que si on explique un truc en
disant il faut pas oublier la cause et
le combat c'est ça qui a créé l'attentat
explique-moi quelle est la cause qui a
provoqué le batlan j'aimerais juste
Tentendre là-dessus parce que
regarde-moi dans les yeux s'il te plaît
je te regarde je te dis avec une
gentillesseê avec ton cinéma regarde-moi
dans les yeux là pas du tout me prend
pour tu es en train de de penser que je
fu le regard là mais
quo ré-moi simplement de la fermer quand
je
parle je
jeis su
pasex
vieauris
m'terard réponds juste à ma question
s'il te plaît je t dis si Israël donc a
provoqué quelque part à cause de sa
politique cet attentat explique-moi ce
que la France a fait pour mériter le
batlan c'est extrêmement simple simple
comme réponse comme question maintenant
la réponse va être compliqué parce que
là tu te rends compte que dans ta
dialtique tu sur le
mêmeaureiss répondre s'il vous plaît je
trouve que tu intellectuellement
malhonnête parce que tu fais un lien
s'il vous plat entre de
lien qui n'a pas lieu d'être le Bataclan
est un drame absolu
ditique dique qui a porté atte au cœur
de tous les Français que nous sommes et
dans le Bataclan il y avait des gens de
toute origine de toute confession ils
ont frappé avec une
idéologie comme israë en Israël en
Israël il y a une problématique qui est
celle d'un peuple qu'il faut dissocier
du hamass enfin et d'un peuple que la
politique israélienne tue à petit feu
depuis 56 ans avec aucune espérance
possible d'avoir un état et toute une
génération qui grandit dans cet état
d'esprit et donc une démocratie
politique qui s'appelle Israël avec un
gouvernement que je dis aciie des
Israéliens et encore plus des juif parce
que moi je ne fais jamais la confusion
et j'espère qu'avant la fin on va quand
même dire un mot sur le le scandale
c'était le troisème que je voulais
traiter mais avec beaucoup de
difficultés c'est de ne pas importer le
conflit sur notre sol parce que je pense
effectivement que ce serait dramatique
je ne comprends pas que tu le lien
entre veut te dire fait
que terrorisme DRAM d'accord et et avec
lequel on doit
faire te dit que c'est du terrorisme
dans les estce que j'ai nié que çaétait
pour dis que que j'aié ça c'est ce qu'il
veut dire il veut dire quoi je ve dire
quelque chose de simple au lieu de
parler des causes parle uniquement déjà
du fait et essae au moins de montrer aux
gens que la première chose à dire c'est
de dire on est tous contre le terrorisme
si tu essayes de trouver des causes tu
vas justifier la preuve plein de gens on
compris ici que tu justifia cet acte
donc je te dis
on va faire un autre exemple on prend le
Bataclan qu'est-ce qui peut justifier
l'injustifiable rien rien peut justifier
le batlan rien justifie ce qui s'est
passé samedi désolé Karim mais tu VO
bien que ton
discoursour discourse les
prop pas de quand les G écouter ce que
tu as dit à
radiog cette
malhonné direct c'est en direct les G
dis
R est direct ous ni ramas ni DIC ni
terroriste tu parles de rien radio ALG
je vous encourage à le l'écouter si un
proposz une question à lui poser alle j
derère question est-ce qu' a une
responsabilité politique de l'État
d'Israël à la situation aujourd'hui du
peuple palestinien qui n'a pas d'état je
te rappelle je te pose une question rond
je vais te répondre moi tu m'as déjà vu
tergiverser tu fais çaé allez-y répondez
qui gère la bande de Gaza depuis 2005
question le Gaza g pard à Gaza qui est
parti d'ailleurs de façon unilatérale du
jour au lendemain àon en disant
maintenant vous Grez
çaonsabilité la différence entre toi et
moi c'est que moi je suis rien jeis
écout automatiquement une responsabilité
politique on l'a dit hier je le dis tout
le temps pourquoi est que le Hamas est
une création de N tu r compte que jeux
je te des israli qui disent des
diplomates je ne relais que les paroles
de ceux qui de l'Intérieur ont expliqué
sa stratégie est-ce que c'est une
stratégie à laquelle tu crois ou pas
écoute non seulement j'ai honte pour toi
mais je te
direespond ça correspond à un chef du
ramas hier qui expliquait qu'il y avait
pas de victime civil et que donc
évidemment que quand il découpait en
morceau qu'il tuait des habitants il est
considéré comme des com
combatist rien à voir dans la situation
écoute-moi mais tu n'écoutes pas tu fais
si on faisait un décompte comme aux
échecs tu serais à 100 non très bien
laiss et pas a pas besoin de personne
pour le critiquer en Israël tous les
jours et toi tu n pas pas alors moi j'y
suis tous les jours
laisse-mo monologue ce so on pe pas par
tous les jours on le critique du matin
au soir on n pas besoin de personne pour
critiquer la politique israélienne elle
est critique en Israël plus que
n'importe où ailleurs parce que au moins
ils connaissent ce pays deuxièm mais
c'est important la responsabilité
d'Israël elle est bien dans un sens et
dans l'autre parce que il manag leur
relation depuis des années avec non
seulement la bande de Gaza administrée
par le Hamas entité terroriste élu quand
même à 77 % tu te rappelles puisquon
avait parlé par les Gazaouis et de
l'autre côté une pseudo Autorité
palestinienne qui est au pouvoir depuis
plus de 18 ans
ref ce qui justifie Fran tap C de
résu des dizaines de trait refusé par
les PAL une dernière
question
pouro
tuce rép des centaines de résolutions de
l'ONU non respect je peux est-ce que je
peux par tu as dit que le tu as dit que
le avait été créé par Israël et par Nat
est-ce que tu R n par tu la bêtise mon
Dieu s'il vous plaît si on pouvait
effacer ça de vos mémoir il faudrait le
faire tu seras ridicule à vie en disant
un truc
pareil décapitations
comm
lescnaissance merci tout la vérité qui
compte merci